- [Voiceover] Let's
start becoming familiar
with our parts of speech.
And we're gonna start with
the two most fundamental ones.
First, the noun, which you
will often see described
as a person, a place or a thing.
And we're also gonna talk about verbs.
A verb is something that
is some type of action.
And at first this might seem a little bit
hard to understand,
what is this word noun,
this word verb?
But as we take, do a bunch of examples,
this will hopefully it'll
make a little bit more sense.
So let's first look at
this first sentence.
Bill likes dessert.
So I encourage you to pause the video,
look at each of these words
and say is that a person, place or thing?
Or is it some type of action?
Or is it neither?
And so it wouldn't be a noun or a verb.
Let's do it together.
So in Bill likes dessert,
Bill is a person.
So it is a person, place or thing.
So this, the word Bill is a noun.
So that right over there,
Bill, that is a noun.
And then Bill likes dessert.
So likes is not a person, place or thing.
That would not be a noun.
But dessert is a person, place or thing.
In this case it is a thing.
So dessert is also gonna be a noun.
So we have two nouns, we have
two nouns in this sentence.
Bill and dessert.
But what is likes?
What's the action that Bill is taking?
Bill likes dessert, so
likes is going to be a verb.
Or likes is a verb.
So that is a verb.
Let's do another example.
I slept.
Once again pause the video,
see if you can figure out
the noun and the verb.
Alright so we start with I,
is I a person, place or thing?
Yeah its a person, its whoever
is saying the sentence.
In this case, I guess its me.
So this would be a noun.
So let me do that in our noun color
which is going to be yellow.
So this is a noun, I.
And then slept is not a
person, place or thing
its an action, its what I did, I slept.
So slept is a verb.
So we had one noun, one verb.
Let's look at this next sentence.
The pretty pig took a bath.
Once again, pause the
video and see if you can
identify the persons, places
or things or the nouns
and see if you can identify any verbs.
So the pretty pig, and we're
gonna cover what the is
but the by itself is not
a person, place or thing,
i just did, to kind of get a little ahead,
its called an article
and we'll talk more
about that in the future.
Pretty by itself is not
a person, place or thing
and its also not an action,
so let's ignore that for now
and we'll get back to that.
But pig, that is a person, place or thing.
So pig is a noun, pig is a noun.
And then took, not a
person, place or thing.
A, not a person, place or thing.
Bath, well a bath, a bath is a thing.
So that is also a noun.
So those are the nouns right over there.
So pig, pig and bath.
Now what's our verb?
There's one verb in this sentence.
And its what the pig did,
the action the pig did,
the pig took, took
something, it took a bath.
So that's our action right over there,
that's our verb.
Took is our, is our verb.
I think we're getting the hang of this,
lets keep going.
The funny bird ran quickly.
Once again, pause the video,
see if you can work it out.
Well the by itself is not
a person, place or thing.
Funny by itself it not
a person, place or thing
and neither of these are actions.
Bird is a person, place or thing,
its a thing.
So bird, bird is a noun.
Bird is a noun.
Ran, that's what the bird did,
that's the action, so
that's gonna be a verb.
And quickly is neither an action nor is it
a person, place or thing
and we'll study this part
of speech in the future.
Let's look at the next sentence.
He ate the watch.
Pause the video, see if you
can figure out the nouns
and the verbs.
So he, well that's a person,
so that's going to be
that is going to be a noun.
Ate, that's an action,
that is going to be a verb.
The by itself isn't a
person, place or thing
but watch is, watch is a thing,
so that's gonna be our noun.
One more sentence, Dogs are silly.
Well dogs are clearly a
thing, so that's our noun.
Now the verb might be a
little bit harder to see,
what's the action?
Well the dogs are silly,
you can say the action
they are taking is being silly,
and that's just something they do.
So this one might be a little
bit harder to understand.
But what is the dog doing,
they're being silly.
Are is the action, so
that right over there,
that right over there is the verb.
So hopefully this starts to
give you a hang of things
and we'll look at a lot more examples.
That's really the key of
understanding nouns and verbs.
And we'll also start to think
about what all these other
words are that we haven't labeled yet.